hey I stirs Almir here good seeing you
all with me I have a special guest today
Hey Joe come here producer on payday to
welcome you I came good seeing you
good see you always so we're going to
talk about payday 2 Ultimate Edition for
PC but before we do that we just wanted
to say thank you so much to all the
console Heiser's out there for all your
good wishes your your kind words
regarding the latest DLC and and the
updates for consoles that most wanted we
really appreciate all the feedback and
we read it all and we're so happy to see
you guys being able to play the latest
content available for you and we are
already working on the next batch of
content so stay tuned for that a couple
of weeks ago we had an event that we
called the star stream and during the
start stream we talked about all the
different games we're currently
developing ourselves but also the games
were publishing as a publisher and we
talked about Psychonauts
system shock and so on and so forth but
we also talked about payday 2 and then
what we what did we announce back then
we did allow the ultimate edition that
we currently work at all Ultimate
Edition is a rebuttal of the base game
basically so the base game we have a lot
of DLCs so on baked them in now to the
ordinary base game essentially making an
Ultimate Edition ultimately that's why
we call it the ultimate delicious so up
until now we had an eight to five
percent sale off yeah on all deals here
hello this is what we do today is that
we remove all these C's for the storage
yeah alright so like you I can just said
we had a huge sale it just ended when it
ended we removed all DLC and we're
currently preparing the pay to Ultimate
Edition we're still working out a few
kinks in it so please give us some more
time while we make sure it works
properly we don't want to release
anything unfinished so we really
appreciate your patience in that and
meanwhile like we said when we announced
the Ultimate Edition all future updates
for payday 2 on PC are going to be free
so nothing weird there and any questions
you might have please make sure you
check out the FAQ that we've already
made available there links in the
make sure you check that out if you have
any further questions and if any
question you might have aren't answered
in in the FAQ feel free to ask us in the
forums we'll get back to you as soon as
possible or one of our dear community
community moderators well so I'll live
we have one more thing to say don't we
we do you a Kim thanks we're giving away
5 million copies of PT 2 for free on
theme and we're starting right now so
all you need to do is just go to the PT
2 store page and press install if you
don't have paid it to already and if you
don't you install the game and it's
yours to keep forever and when you do
you also get something else right yes on
the star stream we also announce payday
VR payday VR is coming later this year
and you get beta VR for free if you own
payday precisely so download payday 2
for free now and you get payday 2 VR
later this year for free as well and the
cool thing about that game is that yeah
you should definitely check out the clip
we've already made on it which you can
find in our youtube channel
but you crossed plays yes you can't play
a VR player can play with a PC Hyster so
si that's awesome so definitely make
sure you own played it too if you don't
already and if you already own beta to
make sure your friends that you want to
hide with but they haven't been able to
hide for some reason make sure they get
it because it's free and all future
updates will be free as well under a
limited time yeah cuz we will only be
giving away 5 million copies during a
limited time so make sure you grab it
it's first-come first-served so yeah
it's out there now go get it alright
heisters thank you so much for tuning in
once more listening to us talking about
payday 2 and the future of the game we
are really excited about going live with
a pity to Ultimate Edition we will keep
you posted on that don't worry about it
meanwhile make sure you get all your
wannabe hoisting friends into payday 2
because now is the perfect time to do
that
[Music]